they call me the Mariner shipwreck
handyman the only one keeping a harbor
afloat the side captain a and a hot um a
pleasure to meet you likewise i hope i
don't suppose you'd be willing to lend a
hand and they won't we huh what's their
award medicine I heavens no sign me up
Eagles cold Tanner of tannery okay hull
breach okay get the power tools there's
like a fun hundred [ __ ] things off
the right manner [ __ ] it ok I will do
this whole bridge real quick you know it
just don't build itself [ __ ] I goin
the map of our Harbor yeah holy [ __ ]
it's a big-ass map what the [ __ ] [ __ ]
far as [ __ ] right
hey
he's s we're sucking down a lot of round
ok ok was a mailbox
okay I'm just flying through here
[ __ ] ok I don't want no chubbo until
place is [ __ ] a rat-infested what the
[ __ ] children I don't the [ __ ] if they
get in here ok ok I'll just fly through
here ok and I'm just passing through now
neither make friends klug is this hey
get little effect it here ugh [ __ ]
annoying Jesus hey let's see i can get
there here good god take like 10 years
to get across a chef and I probably with
a fog to hide the [ __ ] graphics
haven't you bet they can do like low
poly shoot hey
hey outside my problems so i'm not gonna
do with it you know i'm just trying to
get through here look at that get how
big is this map
what the [ __ ] are they got a car here
okay yeah fire [ __ ] I'm pretty close
okay great something just [ __ ] woke
up next
we're gonna lighten them up Jesus
okay yeah I need to panic all right get
it by Zuri did it auto saving holy [ __ ]
that scared the [ __ ] out of my finger
the pocket doesn't break anymore right
sweet you're gonna [ __ ] an exploratory
yes
the [ __ ] is that I whole leveled up echo
a quick I remember what the [ __ ] I did
something out
either [ __ ] down there at your show hey
head over there get on their badge here
we discovered anything okay hack attack
hey Juan see if you had anything worth
taking sure thing oh [ __ ] drop them
Kenna Kenna go there John and done now
now cover there good plan move out and
do
take him out down on it Dadda can't get
up it's [ __ ] it faster if I just stuck
into
is that Tanner King house early yep okay
you
is it
you
anyways here pocket get the [ __ ] outta
here too sure
okay at all right where's my [ __ ]
live stream like blah
alright marina you've ended the tannery
they can fix out for Harambee